well you know I've been you know many
verses in my secret garden and now I
like to share the what a few you here
today thank you everybody
well this would be an honor because um
as the bard once said all the world's a
stage and Charlie's been booed off them
all in this first verse you recognize
the classic a a BB a poetic structure
there once was an old man named Ross who
jokes were covered with moss his punch
line was musty his premise was dusty I
wish the gonna exhaust
you're not Oh scuse me what do I do Jess
you Jeff
no I must say you know I'm rather
intrigued by your puffy grotesque
face yeah you know no not only
when I'm next to somebody who faces
grotesque as yours they throw in the
towel man you're a mess man
during your performance I wish I'd get
my own
right now is the best bike